all right Cassie uh where are you from
originally Cassie Fairfax California Bay
Area
tell me about your family growing up um
my family growing up my mom raised me
until I was 12. uh when she passed away
my father passed away a few months
afterwards he was murdered
um after that I was in different Foster
cares until I turned 16 at 16 I got
emancipated and went off on my own how'd
you lose your mom my mom died of AIDS
she had AIDS cancer hep C and a sleeping
disease but in the end she actually
overdosed on oxycontin and internally
bled to death
both your parents were into drugs they
were before I was born my mom actually
was on hella drugs and then found out
she was pregnant got sober uh my dad
threw her over a bridge when she was six
months pregnant so she eventually took
Vicodin and that's how she ended up
overdiding on oxycontin
um my parents originally were from Back
East my dad used to sell for the mob and
he decided to rip them off
so they ran to California my mom stayed
there my dad went back that's how he
ended up getting murdered my sister
found him beaten to death in his own
apartment
um so that was fun my mom got diagnosed
when I was two years old they gave her
six months to live she punched the
doctor and said you're not God and she
didn't even live another 10 years
um I was one of the first kids to be
born without AIDS of two parents that
had AIDS and conceived and breastfed so
that was interesting
um not a whole lot of fun growing up
because my mom was on the news a lot she
grew up hot she sued our town and won
and a lot of people were afraid of AIDS
and thought I might get it or have it or
something
so that didn't go very well so your
childhood must have been difficult it
was interesting
um proposition 215 is medical marijuana
so when my mom was really sick she grew
a few pot plants on her deck the police
came in arrested me kicked in her door
when we had a living nurse and she ended
up suing them and winning so she helped
write proposition 215 which was a
legalization of medical marijuana
so that was cool I guess I mean what was
your high school years like my high
school
my high school
so my first foster parents they never
had children but they took in foster
kids and
it was more of an abusive [__] up
situation
this woman had
I want to leave him for a [__]
boyfriend who ended up putting hands on
me and it was my fault so I got kicked
out of that
um before going before my mom passed
away I thought I was going to be a
doctor
I had a really hard time coping with her
passing and ended up being a raging
alcoholic doing as many drugs as I could
but I played soccer which kept me going
through high school for a while I did
graduate early but
mostly I went to Raves I drank as much
as I could I smoked weed I did acid
mushrooms ecstasy
you name it I was doing it
um I think I would teased the first time
when I was 14.
that was scary
but it was a learning experience
um yeah I went to high school in Marin
small hippie town
and then I went to a continuation school
because I got kicked out for taking my
principal in the shin
because he said obviously I wasn't
raised right when I didn't go to school
because they tried putting me on
antidepressants after my mother died
when I said I was supposed to be
depressed because my mother died
and so I kicked my principal
and they expelled me
and drugs have been a part of your life
kind of drugs have been pretty much a
part of my life since I was mostly an
alcoholic and then I really needed a
root canal and someone threw a rock at
me and shattered my kneecap and I could
not get any painkillers or anything and
my boyfriend was like oh I'm gonna go
get you some heroin I thought he was
joking I'd never done heroin before I
didn't know how to chase the dragon
nothing
so he shotgun did me I threw up uh I was
so high I did not care because I could
still feel my face like vibrating
but uh
it was
it was different and I liked it and now
I defend which is a little bit worse but
at least I'm not shooting up
um yeah
yeah you came to L.A how long ago I came
out like three years ago uh
in between the time of getting here and
being in La we had my boyfriend and I
had a very successful pop business and
it got shut down right before covid and
we lost everything everything so we
moved to Santa Clarita to stay with his
uncle who ended up being a raging
alcoholic literally drank a gallon of
vodka a day with spitting our food call
me conscious weird weird things so he
kicked us out
um I never been to La before we ended up
camping at Union Station if you know
what that is it is a place of all the
crazies
um I used to wake up to a dude that
stayed next to us standing over me
masturbating I had a stalker I got
jumped on the first week I was in LA
and that's I mean I've been beat up a
couple times for racism because I didn't
want to get down with a dude all sorts
of [__] [__] la la is hard
where do you stay now you're on the
street
um I just got into a shelter actually
about a month ago
so how do you support yourself
right now I boost
um I steal things and I sell them
I'm trying to get I just got gr
supposedly we'll see if that comes
through and I'm trying to get better at
life trying to see if I get a job again
again being addicted to a drug that
makes you sick if you don't do it
[__] that [__] up hella bad how old are
you I'm 33. 33. do you have kids no kids
no kids no kids I want kids
but
I think I'm getting too old for that and
my situation doesn't really
suggest a happy life for a child I don't
you want to give your children a better
life than what you had so
you know I've always wanted to be able
to do that but haven't had the stability
I guess did you feel like you're
possibly walking in the footsteps of
your parents
yeah yeah I do and
you know
people don't want to end up like this it
starts with trauma and not just one
thing it's it's kind of a cascading
effect and I always think back to like
you know if she didn't die what if
things been different but at the same
time
would I have still been an addict I
still would have had the same issues
maybe I would have had more support
but what I've still made the same poor
choices I'm one of those people that
understands if I do something it's going
to resolve this way and yeah I still do
it
why I don't know it's in mind of an
addict I guess
but
every day I try to make things a little
bit better
or at least I tell myself that
um
were there things you would have done
differently if you
absolutely absolutely I mean going back
to seeing the day my mother died I
watched it get worse somewhere somewhere
and she didn't want to go to the
hospital and finally I called the
paramedics
um they told me that she internally bled
to death she needed a blood transfusion
I'm type O blood I could have gave her a
transfusion
they asked me to leave the hospital room
when she tried pulling out the the
breathing tube instead they gave him a
morphine and put her down and I asked
them to give her a week on life support
and they said oh she's not gonna make it
a week I went home to go to sleep and
when I did that they pulled her off
so starting there would have been the
first thing I did differently
and then
just taking my school my academics a lot
more serious
I would have definitely
try to do that more seriously
I think I waste a lot of opportunities I
had being too caught up
in my own head and depression and drug
use
to move forward
the same time I had a very close close
group of friends growing up who didn't
like my boyfriend who I'm still with
kind of and uh when I got with him they
had all told me to [__] off or they were
gonna [__] off either date him or lose
my friends so I stuck with him
10 years later he got hit in the back of
the head and spends 12 hours a day
picking up [__] trash
that's all he does all day he gets high
and picks up trash
inside
what emotions do you go through living
this lifestyle you get him you depressed
I'm sure
depression fear I mean I
I try to tell myself not to regret but
there is Regret because life is precious
and when you go through so much life
not experience like not enjoying it
it is regretful what's your biggest
regret
I mean I always want to have kids
probably not having a family and not
having my [__] together enough to be a
mom
you know
like my mom my own mother she was really
sick like we had a Living Nurse we had
welfare Christmases and I always wanted
to be a doctor I always wanted to help
people that were in that situation
and I'm obviously never gonna do that
but
I hope at some point I got my [__]
together enough to at least be a
counselor for people that have gone
through the same [__] that I have you
know when I was younger I used to work
with other kids I had parents that had
AIDS and had done and I found that
really really helpful to myself because
it's nice to be able to help people
um but down here you know I think I'll
take my shirt off my back for someone
and then they end up just [__] me
and I think that's probably one of my
bigger problems always want to trust
people and help someone out when they
just want to use and to take advantage
you still have hope for the future
some days some days I do some days I
don't
um
you know every day is a is a different
mind game between the depression the
drug use and just
the weight of the world
it's harder than being down here like I
don't really know anyone all about
everyone I meet seems like they either
want to [__] me or [__] me over
and it makes it hard to keep going
it's hard without any friends it's hard
having one person you know be a shadow
of the person they once were and feel
responsible for them I don't have
children but I have a 40 year old man
child that I have take care of
and it's sad
It's just sad
so much potential lost you know
like I had an opportunity to play ODP
soccer like I played in Australia I was
catching my high school soccer team
catching on my club team
and now I'm a [__] druggie that was
on the street going nowhere
what was your favorite memory as a kid
my favorite memory as a kid
hmm
going to my first concert Blink 182
concert and that's one of my favorite
memories
for sure we're going to Hawaii Hawaii
was a lot of fun too
my mom had a good harvest and took us
and 10 people to the Embassy Suites on
Maui for three weeks
first time I was on anywhere for
vacation it was [__] amazing
it was definitely amazing what's your
biggest fear now
I'm gonna end up generally got her alone
No One's Gonna care No One's Gonna Know
do you have any family at all
yeah yeah I do the siblings I have a
half sister who I don't speak to
um
she's got her own set of problems and
one of them is that everyone owes her
something and I used to try to help
support her I used to send her money one
of the last times I was in town she
lives back East I told her that I had
warrants and told her not to [__] around
and she goes and kicks a windshield out
in a cab and has the cops come
and since I was in the plot business I
used to take 100 pounds across country
once a month on the Greyhound bus so I
had all this weed with me and my sister
is going around trying to get us
arrested and then she has the audacity
to call me from jail to bail her out and
I said [__] you and she said you're not
going to bail me out with your drug
dealer money
like that's all I need
so I don't talk to her
um but my father was one of 17 children
and I got 50 first cousins literally
my dad is one of 17 children
Irish Catholics man they drink on Friday
go to confession on Saturday so
everything's all good for them but
I don't know my family is drunken
abusive in a different manner
that's why I ended up staying in
California
when I was four years old my dad
kidnapped me and took me back yeast but
he was so [__] up he couldn't have
custody so I got thrown in foster care
there as well and then my grandmother
got me
but my whole family they're all raging
alcoholics that think their way is the
best way even though
they just do the same [__] to each other
smack each other around lie cheat steal
but they go to confession
so
they're Godly well it was the craziest
thing you saw in your childhood
uh the woman that lived downstairs for
me she had two kids this woman was on
meth and on heroin and not only did her
math little lava blow up she blamed her
daughter for kicking out her candle and
lying the fire but this woman swore up
and down that she wasn't on drugs and
then her kids came up to our house
saying that her mom turned purple this
[__] OD'd with a needle in her arm in
front of her kids so we had to go get
ice from the store down the street carry
this woman and put her in a bathtub her
oldest daughter was in third grade her
youngest daughter was in like first
grade and after this when she comes too
like she comes up like she got hit with
adrenaline she goes that's weird I
wasn't on drugs I had an allergic
reaction
this woman was terrible
terrible it sounds like the environment
you grew up in
yeah you kind of made you destined to
have the
this rough life you've you're living now
I I think about that all the time like
people give people such a hard time that
are on the street or that are dry legs
but trauma starts somewhere and if that
trauma's not treated
it manifests and into things that people
can't deal with and they they try to do
with a pain and the issues by covering
it up and you can only cover something
up for so long
before it takes you over or before you
have to do substances or something to
ignore it like
you know first time I ever got bullied
when I was a kid I went home and told my
mom and she straight up asked me did you
push them back and I was like no I
didn't want to get in trouble and she
goes well I don't want to [__] hear
about it you push him back harder and
they'll never push you again
and I understand that because
if you don't stand up for yourself who
else is
and
even though life was hard
you have to play the game even harder if
you want to succeed and it's that
feeling bad for yourself and oh poor me
is what ruins your chances of going of
being a better person
but getting over that that initial hump
and loving yourself is the hardest part
I feel like because if you don't love
yourself you can't love anyone else and
you're never gonna make your life any
better
you think there's a better chance that
you'll
spend the rest of your life on the
streets or or get clean
God I hope not I I
saw after three years I just got my
insurance on Friday so I'm trying to get
on methadone on Monday so I'm praying
that that works well for me and I can
actually stick to it
but one day at a time so
I mean Cassie what would you say is the
most important lesson you've learned in
your life
Parish every moment you have cherish the
people that are close to you
you know love your family love your
friends and enjoy what you can
you know don't take anything for granted
don't take anyone for granted
and learn from your mistakes the best
you can
all right Cassie thank you so much for
sharing your story
okay there's lots of luck out there
thank you